there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
who the hell is this i'm a friend of
sully's sally doesn't have any friends i
should know i'm one of them you are a
collector well i dabble i don't have one
my family has been looking for this
portion for a very long time so much
blood
pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
oh my god i should never come out to
play with that big boy's way in cause
you're about to get a proper scottish
welcome
what
oh crap
well it wasn't quite 30 feet yeah it was
actually 40 feet i was just trying to be
modest wow hey mark do you know what the
word uncharted means it means something
brand new never before seen hasn't ever
been put on a map yet and that's what
this movie is the story uncharted the
action uncharted the locations are
uncharted the characters so the
characters are maybe a little bit
charted because they're based on an
incredibly popular video game franchise
nice it's just a little charted yeah
uncharted exclusively in movie theaters
welcome back everyone sony just rocked
the uncharted trailer with tom holland
and mark wahlberg there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs here for the uncharted
game series so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i've only played some of the games but
it's actually a really solid game series
if you're not really familiar with the
franchise and it's sort of like tomb
raider cross with indiana jones if you
gotta get that vibe from the trailer
here also fun easter egg because tom
holland to spider-man we're going to be
watching him in spider-man no way home
in a couple months and this is coming
out in february a couple months after
that they just teased the big spider-man
versus venom crossover with tom hardy's
version of venom and this movie is the
reason why andy circus wound up being
hired to direct venom look to be carnage
because sony wanted that verse venom
director to work on this he also did the
zombieland movies so if you remember the
comedic elements from the first venom
film like sort of an action comedy the
way they played his relationship with
the venom symbiote you kind of get the
same tone from this movie the way they
play the jokes in the trailer also in
that behind the scenes featurette with
mark wahlberg joking with tom han i
won't punch you if you don't get in the
way of my sword anymore that also
happens to the actors all the time too i
really do think that he accidentally hit
him on set while they were filming but
if you played the games i believe this
movie is meant to be a new story just
riffing on some easter eggs from the
previous games like they're not directly
adapting the plot of one of the games
this is meant to be a little bit earlier
in nathan drake's career because tom han
obviously very young person in a lot of
the uncharted games nathan drake is
quite a bit older but as you can see tom
holland is playing nathan drake and mark
wahlberg is playing sully he doesn't
have the mustache from the video game
series but he's also a much younger
version of sully and if you've been
following the news about this movie for
a long time they've been trying to make
an uncharted movie for a long time for a
lot of that period mark wahlberg was
actually trying to become nathan drake
in the film but that version of the film
just didn't wind up working out for
whatever reason but enough time went by
he got a little too old so they just
turned him into the sully character on
the other side of the coin nathan
fillion also did an uncharted fan film a
long time ago that you may been familiar
with so this is not the first attempt to
do a big uncharted project i don't
believe the braddock character here is
from the video game series but most of
you if you did play the game series will
recognize chloe frazier she's a former
love interest of sully she shows up in
several of the games almost all the
games and is a major character across
the entire series she's also the villain
of some of the games and becomes a
protagonist of some of the later games
so she's kind of a catwoman like
character in that sense in the way that
she flip-flops between bad and good but
she's not meant to be evil or good
remember this is about treasure hunting
so there's a lot of opportunists out
there all's fair in love and war
turnabout is fair play some of the
really obvious easter eggs that you may
have noticed if you've been playing the
game series for a long time are the
shout out for nathan's brother sam so
even though i wouldn't really consider
this a big easter egg sam is a big plot
element of the games because for most of
the game series you believe that he died
a long time ago but then winds up
resurfacing in a later game i think it
was uncharted 4 where he resurfaces and
reveals that he's been alive this whole
time and asked nathan his younger
brother for helping finding this new
epic treasure so because this movie is
taking place earlier in nathan drake's
timeline when he's younger he still
believes his brother is dead or missing
somewhere and when he mentions his
brother sam and they whip out the ring
that's also a big video game easter egg
this is the ring of sir francis drake
someone who nathan drake tells everyone
as his ancestor but secretly he's just a
historical figure a historical explorer
that nathan drake was inspired by so he
changed his last name to nathan drake so
people would believe that he was related
to sir francis drake he was a famous
british explorer during the reign of
queen elizabeth the first during the
late 1500s who was knighted by her then
sent on a mission to find this secret
fabled city of aram then later wound up
faking his death so that he could search
for the treasure of el dorado everyone
is familiar with el dorado fabled city
of gold but that whole theme of him
faking his own death to search for some
secret other treasure sort of plays in
with the resurfacing of sam drake his
brother which is why they're mentioning
his brother while they're also
mentioning the ring of sir francis drake
because sir francis drake faked his
death just like his brother sam faked
his death and even though his brother
sam kind of looms large over the story
over his backstory i don't know if he's
going to actually be a character during
this movie or if he won't surface till
the sequels but i'm assuming at some
point they will reveal the actor who
plays sam like he'll have some sort of
cameo scene or at least show him in a
flashback then the way they end the
trailer is obviously a big easter egg
too the cargo plane that's right out of
uncharted 3 there's this big cargo plane
sequence during the game so they're
directly adapting this part of the video
game series i expect they do that for
some of the other parts of the film too
some of the big action scenes this big
party scene is also very similar to a
sequence during uncharted 4 when his
brother sam has come back where nathan
sam and sully all have to infiltrate
this auction to try and secure an
artifact where they all have to get
dressed up and basically try to steal
something while this giant party is
going on also the lost treasure ship
they're staring at here seems like it's
right out of uncharted 4 as captain
avery ship that's the mysterious
treasure that sam drake resurfaces for
telling nathan drake oh i've been alive
this whole time please help me find this
captain avery treasure so like i said if
captain avery's ship is going to be in
this movie then sam is also probably
going to be featured at some point in
this movie this big rooftop chase is
also very similar to some rooftop chases
that they have in the uncharted series
especially a younger version of nathan
drake being chased across the rooftops
tom holland's costume during the movie
is also inspired by one of nathan
drake's most iconic looks like he has a
couple different looks throughout the
game series but this is one of his most
iconic outfits and if you have been
playing the game series for a long time
or you're a fan of the uncharted music
even though they have the led zeppelin
ramble on song peppered throughout the
trailer at the beginning of the trailer
you briefly hear a piano theme that's
reminiscent of nate's theme from the
uncharted games it's just called nate's
theme basically it's his theme song if
you haven't played any of the games i
would recommend you check them out
they're fantastic i've only got a couple
of them so i do need to pick up some of
the others but if you spotted any easter
eggs from the game series that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments like i said next
big tom holland movie is going to be
spiderman no way home we'll probably get
a new trailer for that sometime in
november so of course i'll do all kinds
of spider-man videos for that and then
i'll talk more about spider-man and
venom crossover i still think that there
are some people out there that have not
had a chance to see venom because of
lockdown protocols there was a really
cool announcement recently about marvel
actually working on a legit new hulk
movie so i will do a video for that next
make sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss anything everyone click here
for my brand new spiderman no way home
trailer video for that new footage and
click here for my venom let there be
carnage post credit scene in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the
next one
you